all right Steph ready
Stephen Curry do not rely on him to run
your team
he was about five six looks like a
little kid 150 pounds soaking wet that
was when I first really understood
I'm Different how did I get here I was
the undecided scrawny kid that was just
trying to figure out how to make it
Steph Curry is hurt I was overwhelmed by
everything how would I respond
let the work begin
when you are an underdog you have to
take what is yours
for the sweet 16.
it's not about proven other people wrong
it's about proving himself right
and that feeling of being underrated
always being part of the drive that
keeps me going Stephen Curry underrated
only on Apple TV Plus